[Musique]
c'est violent justement c'est la
priorité
l'insécurité la priorité numéro un pour
les français qui vont voter oui
malheureusement une relation des faits
de violence des faits d'agression des
actes racistes antisémites
les chiffres sont sont en effet
inquiétant moi je ne peins gens pensent
pas néanmoins que la présence de l'état
se résume à une présence policière
je crois que dans des territoires qui
sont difficiles parfois ce que l'on
constate avant que la violence et le
retour de la police municipale avant que
la violence n'explose c'est finalement
la démission progressive des des
services publics des services régaliens
de l'état
on voit qu'il n'ya plus de politique de
la ville qu'il n'y a pas de politique
d'animation pas de politique d'insertion
et puis pour avoir suivi les questions
de police et de justice pendant très
longtemps pendant mon mandat de
parlementaire je pense qu'il faut pas
avoir d' approche simpliste la prison
c'est une machine à récidive
on le sait depuis fort longtemps et que
l'on construit excusez moi je vous ai
pas interrompu les ont conçus et plus on
construit on construit de places de
prison puis on incarcère en france et
donc on est régulièrement condamnée en
raison des cif de surpopulation
je crois en effet que chaque délit et
chaque crime doit faire l'objet d'une
sanction et d'une punition néo moi je ne
pense pas qu'on règle les questions de
sécurité les questions de troubles à
l'ordre public
les questions de désordre uniquement par
la case répressive skis ce qui manque
depuis des dizaines d'années ça a été le
cas au début des années 80 par exemple
quand on avait une vraie réflexion sur
la politique de la ville sur la
politique d'insertion sur la politique
d'accompagnement
je crois je crois que vous mais vous ne
voulez pas entendre madame ne voulait
pas entendre madame vous ne voulez pas
entendre madame pas que la police oui
mais
m'interrompez dangereuse le sont parce
que j'avais dit ça je ne jouais pas mal
à garder les cheveux n'est pas entendre
c'est que en france comme partout
ailleurs la prison ça produit de la
récidive ça produit des délinquances a
produit de la violence quand les gens
sortent et qui ne sont pas accompagnés
donc la solution que vous donnez et
paraît simple et par est alléchante mais
le résultat à la fin c'est des
territoires encore plus soumis à la
dangerosité des trafiquants des violents
des voleurs des gens qui ne respectent
pas l'ordre et dédicacer sa autre
solution verser des millions dans la
policière journée de violences la voix
changé et rien n'a changé de nature
on est violent plus jeunes par exemple
on n'est plus seulement dans cette zone
et violent à l'égard des représentants
de l'état ce qui n'était pas nécessaire
la semaine venant essentielle mais
sociétal dit le criminologue alain bauer
justement dans ses conclusions sur cette
augmentation de la violence aujourd'hui
[Musique]